[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuántas veces te preguntaron de chico
que te gustaría hacer cuando seas grande
a mí muchas y siempre decía banquero y
presidente de argentina
bueno banquero no fui presidente tampoco
por ahora ya mi madre me sigue diciendo
que me postulé que en algún momento voy
a llegar pero bueno veremos
sin embargo trabajé en los últimos 18
años de mi vida en el sistema financiero
en bancos en áreas de inversiones
y uno de los temas que más me hizo ruido
ni bien ingresé a mi primer trabajo fue
como maneje mi finanzas me vea recibido
de licencia de administración había
estudiado cuatro años sin embargo a
nivel personal en mi primer trabajo lo
peor que hice en ese momento fue manejar
como un desastre mis finanzas personales
imagínense yo había invertido no sólo
dinero sino tiempo que es lo que siento
que tengo más importante en mi vida
estaba manejando en ese momento en la
financiera puntos de tercero
administrando inversiones no podía
entender como yo me manejaba tan mal con
mis propias finanzas
en ese momento lo viví como un fracaso
para mí eso fue como terrible
sin embargo siento que gracias a eso su
aprendiz
y hoy lo vivo como una anécdota parte de
ese aprendizaje
de acuerdo al mes de haber ingresado ese
primer trabajo se acerca un ejecutivo de
cuentas del banco y me dice martín te
entrego dos tarjetas una de débito y una
de crédito la tarjeta de débito para que
puedas cobrar tu sueldo y la tarjeta de
crédito con mil dólares adicionales que
el banco te está otorgando para que
puedas comprar te lo que te gusta 22
años tenía cuando me dijeron que tenía
un crédito de 1.000 dólares dije es
hermoso esto o sea ni me conoce dentro
un medio de trabajar y ya me dan mil
dólares para gastar
se está contento en ese momento al mes
empecé a recibir el resumen de cuenta
que en ese momento llegaba en papel o
iba por mail whatsapp pero será en papel
y adosado el resumen de cuenta me venían
publicidades
y por todos lados por mes me llegaban un
aviso publicitario que decía alcanza la
vida que crees son y a lo que lo que
vivís y suecia cuánta insistencia en
querer comprar en querer utilizar la
tarjeta que en un momento garry dije ya
que me insiste en tanto pero utiliza y
que hice reviente la tarjeta
directamente de los mil dólares que
tenía y compre compre lo que en ese
momento sentía que tenía ganas
y me sentía feliz o sea deja bueno me
estoy dando un gusto bárbaro sin embargo
al mes empecé una carrera por querer
equilibrar mi economía
resulta que cuando vino el resumen de
cuenta yo ya no miraba la publicidad con
todo esto hermoso que decía usar la
tarjeta compra te ate el gusto si no
miraba la línea que decía lo que tenía
que pagar y no podía pagar entonces que
dice primer error pague el pago mínimo
porque no podía pagar el total de la
cuenta
y así me siguiente el pago mínimo
aumentaba y yo volvía a pagar el pago
mínimo
la realidad
es que esta deuda incrementándose y yo
empecé en tranquilizarme y sentía todo
el tiempo conversaciones conmigo mismo
que decía bueno sabe tener a un momento
un aumento de sueldo puede ser con mi
jefe hace cuatro meses que estoy
trabajando acá de bien sé que estoy
haciendo bien las cosas que me podría
aumentar nada de eso sucedió nunca me
llegó un aumento de sueldo y la deuda lo
peor era cada vez mayor
que empecé a hacer en esos cuatro meses
estaba dilatando la resolución no estaba
dejando como algo todo al azar de que en
algún momento se iba a resolver no sé si
les pasó eso alguna vez
un día leí que las personas tendemos
primero a ir más lento para resolver una
situación y luego cuando nos llega esa
fecha de vencimiento aunque sea mental
queremos acelerar y hacer todo rápido
entonces dije bueno no voy a esperar ese
momento para sentirme mal entonces que
hice empecé a reducir los gastos pero
que yo era impensado con 22 años que lo
único que quería era gastar y consumir
estaba reduciendo gastos para pagar una
deuda de una tarjeta
y en un momento cuando ya calculaba que
tenía un dinero ahorrado por mes que me
podía permitir pagar otra cosa dije de
hacer un crédito personaje con ese
crédito personal pude cancelar la
tarjeta
obviamente no refinancie la tarjeta por
el mismo refinanciamiento la tarjeta
porque era mucho más caro y ni hablar si
seguía pagando el pago mínimo en
impagable era una bola de nieve cada vez
mayor
me costó entender cómo funciona el
sistema de financiamiento de las
tarjetas y más aún cómo utilizarlo a mi
favor
todos estos temas que me pasaron empecé
a leer
y les voy a compartir un poco de
información de las lecturas que tuve
los pequeños gastos del barco lo decía
benjamín franklin es un inventor
estadounidense que entre ellos estudió
todos temas de la electricidad inventó
el pararrayos
estos pequeños gastos nosotros los
llamamos comúnmente hormigas y
representan el 80 por ciento del
promedio mensual del gasto una persona
bueno ahora me doy cuenta que las
hormigas también son condicionantes y
determinan nuestra economía
sin embargo
además para un gran gasto como puede ser
queremos comprar un auto un televisor
vemos cuál es el valor total utilizamos
inteligencia financiera que hacemos
calculamos la cuota si un televisor sale
40 mil pesos decimos bueno tengo que
ahorrar 4 mil pesos por mes
sin embargo para estos pequeños gastos
llamados hormigas no somos siquiera
capaces de llevar registro alguno los
invito a cualquiera ustedes que le
pregunten a sus amigos sus familiares a
sus conocidos a ustedes mismos y traten
de recordar que gastaron un día la
semana anterior
que nos sorprende la respuesta
entonces estas lecturas a mi me ayudaron
te voy a contar una mas robert kiyosaki
autor de muchos libros entre ellos padre
rico padre pobre dice paguen se primero
a ustedes mismo que significa que si
ustedes reciben un ingreso un sueldo
primero deberían separarse un porcentaje
para ahorrar y luego gastar sin embargo
el 75% de la población que hace primero
gasta consume le paga a todos y después
lo último que hace dice me está quedando
dinero a mí para ahorrar
tal vez sentimos que el ahorro es un
sacrificio y a largo plazo
todo estos temas me ayudaron a mí a
cambiar hábitos sin embargo siempre me
quedo dando vuelta en mi mente el hecho
de las emociones y cómo afectan en la
relación con el dinero
y lo que somos capaces de hacer para
obtener algo por ejemplo si estamos
contentos
qué hacemos tenemos empatía entonces
estamos dispuesto a escuchar una persona
que se acerque nos quiere vender algo
ahora sí estamos tristes salimos
corriendo de compras
quizás buscando un poquito de felicidad
esa es nuestra forma de actuar
entonces yo me pregunto qué nos pasa con
nuestras emociones
como nos llevamos sentimos que nos
gobiernan
y respecto al dinero en esencia no es
más ni menos que una cuestión de poder
el poder de construir o el poder de
destruir
a través del dinero podemos expresar
nuestras ideas y nuestra creatividad o
nuestra frustración o nuestras malas
intenciones
el dinero en sí nos permite transformar
ese sueño en la vida en que vivimos
y algo tengo bien en claro y algo es
seguro de acuerdo a cómo te relacionas
con el dinero
o vos dominas a el dinero o el dinero te
dominará a vos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]